the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so we have an interesting class today
we're going to be taking this IV curve
that we've so laborious ly setup and
understood sorry about that and now we
will subject to it to illumination so
that's the essence of our lecture today
the diode under illumination and as part
of today's lecture we have some
wonderful little kits over there in the
corner where we'll actually be testing
IV curves of solar cells so I hope some
of you brought the computers today and
if not we have some extras up here as
well use so again just to situate
ourselves you're here in fundamentals
we're approaching the end of our
fundamentals section but we still have a
few really important lectures to get
through after we get through the
fundamentals we'll be in a good position
to understand the different technologies
and finally the cross-cutting themes and
our goal is to or at least for the
fundamentals to understand solar cell
conversion efficiency which is the ratio
of output to infant energy and for most
solar cells this breaks down to the
following progression from the solar
spectrum to charge collection and we're
going to be focusing on charge
separation incorporating elements of
either side but mostly focus on charge
separation today reminding everybody of
course that the total system efficiency
is the product of each individual
efficiency and if any one of these is
low the efficiency for the entire system
is low and since folks are tired of
looking at this chart by now have every
single lecture I intend to introduce
something new that follows a similar
pattern does anybody recognize what this
is about
so you have over here some h2o leading
to an it going into an oxygen evolving
complex and light is coming in
essentially exciting up an electron
which is being stored in some form of
chemical energy what is that
photosynthesis right and just like a
solar cell the photosynthetic
photosynthesis conversion efficiency of
the entire system is dictated by the
efficiency of each individual part
roughly it can be broken down into this
little pie chart up here the total
system efficiency in blue is somewhere
depending on the plant somewhere between
around 1% may be as high as 7 or 8
percent depending on very specialized
plants that are experts at converting
sunlight into usable chemical energy and
that
all right is largely due to optical
losses if you can see the absorption
spectrum of chlorophyll of the different
types of chlorophyll here you'll see
large portions of the solar spectrum
that go underutilized right so again
another system that's similar to a solar
cell that the total system efficiency is
the product of each individual component
going along here all right so now what
we're gonna do is just quickly revisit
the diode in the dark and construct the
energy band diagram for PN Junction in
the dark each of you should have on your
desk
these sheets who we don't have them on
the desks we need to pass those out
mm-hmm need to pass those out so we
should have sheets that describe the
essentially the equivalent circuit
diagram the IV characteristics and the
energy band diagram for our PN Junction
in the dark we laborious ly filled this
out last class we're just going to
refresh ourselves to make sure we're all
on the same page and redo it this class
right at the beginning because it's that
important thank you thank you thank you
for those who came to our office hours
and for those who came to the
recitations and we really tried to get
this across for those who are still
struggling let's make sure that you get
this sometime between now and say the
next two weeks because this will feature
prominently on the exam and it's pretty
important for understanding how a solar
cell works so if you would not mind
working directly with your partner the
person who's sitting directly next to
you what let's walk through the diode in
the dark and construct the energy band
diagrams for the diode in the dark I'll
walk you through it as soon as you're
done maybe I'll give you three minutes
to complete that and then we'll progress
to the diode under illumination should
be a lot of fun
good I see convergence I'm a Hmong
several of you so let's move forward
just to review quickly the way I think
about it I first set up in the model
circuit right here with our PN Junction
we have our space charge region also
known as a quasi neutral region also
known as the depletion zone so we have
this region right here that represents
the space charge region now we have so
this is in the dark now we have the
energy band diagram shown right here
where this dashed blue line represents
the chemical potential also called the
Fermi energy throughout the entire
device right here in cross-section and
just to be very very clear we've so far
described the solar cells light coming
in through the top and now we've rotated
this structure by 90 degrees to
represent the PN Junction that's been a
little confusing for some folks
so just to be totally clear in a device
like this one if it were subject to
illumination you would have light coming
in from the side right either the from
the P side or from the N side so to
transfer this into what we've seen so
far where the solar cell device is
facing up toward the Sun you'd have to
rotate this by 90 degrees right just to
make sure we're all clear with
orientations good so we have the Fermi
energy right here the drift and
diffusion currents for electrons
electron diffusion electron drift there
is an abundance of electrons over here
in the n-type side and so they want to
diffuse over to the p-type that's why
the diffusion current is pointing left
once they do to a certain degree they
set up a field the electrons and holes
the mobile charges set up a field and
that creates a drift current that
counteracts the diffusion and once these
two are in equilibrium there's no
current flowing through our device
that's why current is equal to zero
right here and there's also no potential
difference because the Fermi energy the
chemical potential is the same on either
side of that device and so the voltage
output of that solar cell would also be
zero we when we forward bias our device
now we're forcing a separation of or
we're forcing a separation of the
chemical potential on either side of the
device if you connected this to an
external circuit the electrons would
want to flow from this side to that side
but since we're forcing this condition
here with the battery we are reducing
the barrier
right here electrons can now diffuse
over from the n-type into the p-type
side and they do and the diffusion
current increases and that's why we have
current now a positive value we've
defined the electrons traveling to the
left as being a positive current we have
now electrons traveling from the n-type
to the p-type material we reverse bias
our device notice the separation of the
quasi Fermi energies again we have here
one sign of voltage because the right
side is higher than the left and now the
right side is lower than the left so our
voltage sign flips from right to left
over here from positive to negative
values so notice a voltage and now the
current as well the drift current will
outweigh the diffusion current in this
particular case because now the barrier
for electrons to diffuse from the end of
the p-type is very large
they'll have difficulty going from that
side to that side whereas the drift
current is is larger because of the
larger electric field and as a result
the drift current will dominate and so
now instead of electrons flowing from
n-type to p-type where we had defined as
positive current electrons are flowing
from P type two and type in net which we
define as negative current and that's
why our current has changed signs over
here notice that we're in positive
current territory and over here notice
we're in negative current territory also
you'll notice the width of the space
charge region changing as we forward and
reverse bias our device as the barrier
height decreases we have a decrease of
the built in electric field we have a
decrease of the amount of charge on
either side of the junction that's why
the depletion width decreases and the
opposite happens here under reverse bias
so getting to the point where you can
set up a PN Junction and understand how
drift and occur and diffusion currents
come into being in the first place and
then being able to bias your solar or
your bias your diode under different
conditions is a really important
fundamental skill for understanding how
a solar cell works question
so the Fermi energy which we define here
as the chemical potential notice we're
avoiding talking about what's happening
here in the middle until a couple of
lectures from now that gets into a gray
zone where we talk about quasi Fermi
energies we'll get to that in a minute
maybe a couple of lectures but yes the
Fermi energy in the extreme sides right
here near the contacts so you're
contacting your device over here and
you're contacting your device over here
those those terming energies are
different on an absolute energy scale so
there is an energy difference when
you're driving the electrons from one
side to the other notice in this case
right here you would think that the
electrons would want to travel through
an external circuit to come back to the
side because their energy is higher in
the side and lower over here but we're
not we're not illuminating the solar
cell yet we're biasing it using a
battery and this is why we have current
flow coming from this side into that
site we're essentially forcing the
electrons from the n-type into the
p-type material we're pushing them up
that hill with a battery and that's why
we have this diffusion current
dominating in the dark in the dark so we
have a current flowing from right to
left in the illuminated case will have
all of our carriers traveling from left
to right and in the dark this is the
only case in which we have carriers
traveling from right to left and it's
happening because we're using that
battery in the dark to change the
chemical potential another side which in
effect reduces this barrier height and
allows carriers to diffuse from the
n-type and the p-type so you can think
about it as forcing carriers up the
junction right and this is a very useful
technique because in effect what it's
doing in a real device when you have a
two-dimensional device with
inhomogeneities the current will travel
through the weakest point of that PN
Junction wherever the barrier height is
lowest current will begin crowding
through that spot and so it's a way of
probing or testing the quality of your
Junction characteristic in the dark okay
so this is this is a basic of the basics
of PN Junction in the dark let's flip
our page over and now let's try to
imagine what will happen
under illuminated conditions and let's
start out in a very simple case we'll
assume that the principle of
superposition applies here that the
photo excited carriers in other words
when light shines into our device I'm
looking at this one right now or this
one right here and lights coming in and
generating electron hole pair is
essentially exciting electrons across
the bandgap like we described in lecture
three so we have carriers now being
excited across the bandgap what will
happen to those electrons now that
they're in the conduction band where
will they want to go to the right right
okay so what you'll do is set up what's
called an illumination current notice
now at the bottom of the second row here
you have electron diffusion electron
drift and the ill current illah stands
for illumination current so you have a
third arrow here that will have to be
implemented in some way and that will by
the principle of superposition you
should think what happens to your IV
curve as well so let's make an estimate
of what we think should happen then I'll
confer some notes and it will measure
what actually does happen under
illumination when we give it a shot
what is forward and reverse bias mean
when there's no battery this is a very
interesting question so once you start
illuminating your solar cell device and
you start injecting carriers into it the
what will happen is very naturally this
this band alignment that you see right
here this band diagram will begin to
shift toward the forward bias condition
rationale you'll be generating carriers
so they'll be swept over into this
region here one way to think about it is
that you'll be increasing the number of
electrons over here in the number of
holes over here which will naturally
cause the the energy of those electrons
to increase on the side the chemical
potential on the sides increase so one
way to think about it is as you're
illuminating your solar cell more and
more and more you're forcing a forward
bias condition on your device to get the
solar cell to go into reverse bias you
really do need to bias your device you
physically need to device it
yes so when I when I mentioned
illumination current here we're really
talking about the electron illumination
current right worth what what direction
of travel the electrons are taking
inside of our system so yes the
electrons would be traveling from left
to right very astute observation current
is generally described as a flow of
positive charge and in the absence of a
definer or say electrons or holes you
rightly could assume that it would be
the flow of positive charges we're
assuming electrons are flowing here and
the illumination current good all right
so this is very positive I see everybody
has settled on the notion that the
illumination will shift our IV curve
down because of the way we defined
current that if current flows from left
to right that lands us in negative
current territory so that that makes
sense if we shine light on our system we
have electrons flowing from left to
right here that'll put us into negative
territory size shifts the entire thing
down and we would add an illumination
current an arrow pointing to the right
right here which would mean that we
would have current flowing through our
device but there's still no difference
in the chemical potential and either
side there's still a difference in Fermi
energy in the p-type in the n-type which
means our voltage is equal to zero which
means we're intersecting the the y-axis
right here and our little X should be
marked right down here so it's really
just a superposition great okay now what
happens if we forward bias our device
either either because we're adding a
resistor in series to our our solar cell
so instead of a battery there you would
replace that with a resistor or if we're
applying a bias voltages as well we
could also do that under illumination so
we'd still have the illumination current
right and we do through superposition
shift this entire curve down we'd be
operating somewhere in this quadrant
right there right so this we call fourth
quadrant typically one two three four
fourth quadrant this is where power is
coming out of the solar cell device
because if we imagine instead of having
a battery there we have a resistor you
will
the electrons will travel from the
n-type material through that external
load to get to the p-type material where
the chemical potential is lower right
because they'll they'll desire to
minimize the free energy and as a result
they'll deposit that power across that
resistor across that external load in
order to get back to this other side
because that's the only path that they
can travel easily right and so this
entire curve shifts down you have your
red X somewhere in this quadrant over
here and power is flowing out of the
solar cell across that external load so
on the next slide pretty much everything
is right except that Mia culpa I forgot
to replace the battery up there with a
little resistor so you'll want to
correct that in your notes instead of
having the little batteries up there you
can replace those with resistors or a
resistor in series with the battery if
you prefer
since depending on on the illumination
condition the intensity we may have
natural forward bias condition we may
need to apply a bias voltage okay so we
have our IV characteristic like this we
have our red X under forward bias
conditions in the fourth quadrant
denoting that power would be flowing out
of this solar cell device under these
conditions and now the bias is inverted
we have reverse bias conditions and
notice that the current is still has the
same sign so the current is negative
here negative here and negative here so
the current is the net current is always
flowing in the same direction in all
cases because we have this illumination
current because we have this generation
of carriers inside of the material
that's pretty cool that wasn't the case
when we had the device in the dark here
in in forward bias conditions we're
actually forcing carriers from the
n-type material into the p-type material
right but under illumination now we have
all of our carriers traveling from the
p-type into the n-type what's varying is
the potential with that the carrier's
have and of course the total amount of
current as you forward bias more and
more and more this downhill slope here
decreases right so there's less of a
driving force for the carrier's to be
going from the p-type to the n-type and
that's why the current approaches zero
eventually at some point if you keep
forward biasing here the current will be
zero
there will be no net current flow right
because there will be no driving force
for the carrier's to go from the p-type
into the n-type there will be no more
built-in field kind of cool okay so now
we're beginning to wrap our heads around
what's happening to the electrons and
holes during solar cell operation let me
put a little bit of mathematics to this
these are your IV curves the blue is in
the dark and the red is under
illumination and we're focused on this
fourth quadrant right here because this
is a quadrant which power is coming out
of our solar cell device which usable
power is coming out that we can power an
external load why well first off the
voltage is such that we can power an
external load
we have charge separation the electrons
are accumulated over here and they have
higher potential than they do on the
other side which means that there is
there is an incentive for them to go
through the external circuit deposit
there at their power across that
external load to get back to this other
side where their potential is lower
right so the voltage is favorable and
the current is also favorable because
now we have light coming in and this
this generation current is driving the
carriers or it's creating carriers here
in the p-type that can then be driven
toward the n-type because of the
built-in field so the conditions are
just right under illuminated for advice
conditions to drive power through our
external load under all other conditions
of operations of the solar cell we're
putting power into the device not
getting power out of it
this fourth quadrant over here this
forward bias illuminated case is the
only case in which power is coming
usable powers coming out of our solar
cell that we can use so that's why we
focus on this fourth quadrant right here
the illuminated IB curve is to the first
order is just your dark IV curve with a
superposition which we call the
illumination current I sub L and that's
what shifts our entire curve down by
this I sub L right here so this I sub L
that one right there
or that one right there kind of cool all
right what do we think will happen if
our light intensity goes down by a
factor of two
so now if if the amount of sunlight
falling on our solar cell drops by 1/2
what will happen what do we predict will
happen based on this right here the
curve will shift the red curve will
shift up by about half right because the
illumination current is now cut in half
what will happen to the voltage
intersect right here what if the
relation between voltage and current
it's a logarithmic relation right so it
will necessarily be cut in half right
but it'll be cut by whatever this would
be here log of log of 2 so okay so we
have we're beginning to develop an
intuitive understanding of where
electrons are flowing inside of our
solar cells in the dark and under
illumination in a dark is important
because we can test our devices in the
dark and we can still learn a lot about
our solar cell device characteristics in
the dark as well we can under forward
bias conditions in the dark we can force
carriers from our from one side of the
junction to the other the wrong way and
probe for weaknesses in the PN Junction
regions that's helpful and in the
illumination condition obviously we're
testing the total amount of power that's
coming out of our device so again this
is very useful because it's off of this
red curve here that we define the
efficiency or the performance of the
solar cell so what I'll ask folks to do
now is to well we'll begin passing
around these little tools and a last
David Birney Needleman to come up to the
front David is our our lab guru he's the
one who helped build these really was a
driving force behind getting them built
these are IV testers that will allow you
to measure the current voltage
characteristics of solar cells right
here in class and he's going to what
will pass them out while he may be he
comes to the front here and explains how
they work
so now that we have the basic IV curves
rolling in what I'd like you to do is
modify the height of the intensity of
the light and the easiest way to modify
the intensity of the light is to move
the light position up and down right so
modify the intensity of the lights and
see how this IV curve changes note the
y-axis scale which might might change as
well it might rescale depending on the
condition but note the y-axis scale and
see how the the intercept of the of the
y-axis is changing with illumination
intensity give that a shot
all right folks why don't we why don't
we circle back real quick this has been
a good experiment I am very much in
favor of multitasking and browsing so if
you want to keep your experiment running
over the course of the remainder of the
lecture I will certainly have nothing
opposed to testing a few different
illumination conditions and if there's
anything really really important I'm
going to emphasize this is really
important to wake up folks the I sub L
just to really recap here we have this
ideal diode equation the illumination
current coming in from our light source
and in our little setup how many
batteries did you see there look closer
how many batteries do you see total in
our in our setup look it especially if
that light source from two of them right
there's a nine volt in a 1.5 volt all
right so one of them is powering the
light source and we have as well bias to
the solar cell device right so we have a
bit of a combination of the last two
slides right in this case we had the in
the dark we were biasing our solar cell
using the battery and in their
illumination conditions the light itself
was causing the solar cell to become
forward biased but we can add a battery
to sweep the the bias condition of the
device right so even though we have a
natural biasing of the of the solar cell
by the light we can force the solar cell
under different operating conditions
with the battery and so that's
effectively what's happening right here
is you have a combination of both simple
scenarios that we just looked at and
we're building on those components to
really understand the larger system why
might that be important or why might
that be realistic well the light itself
is biasing that particular solar cell
device but that solar cell might be
connected in series with a bunch of
other solar cells in a module right and
those other solar cells might be biasing
that one solar cell so that's why we we
we have to think about the solar cell
device both from the perspective of what
bias condition is it under what
illumination is it under and of course
what's happening around it is it just
powering external load are there is
there a battery connected in series to
it are there other solar cells connected
in series with it okay
yes actually
why having a load with bias device yeah
so let's imagine under illumination
conditions right here what I'm going to
do very very quickly is replace this
battery manually in my slides if
PowerPoint auto-save will allow me with
a resistor so if you'll excuse my quick
introduction here of the resistor now
sorry about little artistic license okay
so now I have my resistor here and my
illumination is coming into the device
from one of the sides it's generating
electron hole pairs I have a
multiplicity of electrons that have now
gone down the hill right it's more
energetically favorable for these
electrons to be on the other side and
what is that done that's raised a
chemical potential decide it's difficult
for them to get back the other way it's
not impossible but it could be more easy
for them to flow through an external
circuit to get back to the other side
and as they flow through that external
circuit they're depositing their energy
across that external circuit
what energy well it's the potential
difference from this side to that side
so that's why the solar cell can be
thought of as under as in forward bias
conditions under illumination with an
external node attached to it of course
the load has to be well matched to the
output of the solar cell device yes the
biasing is because you have a shift in
the chemical potential of this side up
relative to you have a shift of the
n-type side higher than the p-type side
that's a bias anytime you have a
difference in the chemical potential in
one terminal versus the other terminal
of your solar cell you have a bias
whether that's generated by light
whether it's two invited by a battery
right whether it's the energy input to
create that bias is coming from the Sun
or if it's coming from an external
battery that's a matter of detail yes
one can think about this as
oh so the LED in this case could forward
bias your device to I mean it's just
photons photons are forward biasing the
device yeah no that would be very
difficult um what you could what you
could do though is having a bunch of
solar cells connected in series with
this one right that are producing for
power you could shade this device and
then power could be flowing backward
through it right in other words it could
be in the dark right here in a dark
condition and you could be in a reverse
bias condition just because of the way
the other solar cells around it are
behaving if you have a shaded solar cell
for example in module it's imagine a
seagull lands and kind of covers up one
of the cells that will be under reverse
bias and that that could present
problems if the solar cell can't
withstand the reverse bias now this is a
very ideal condition what happens in the
real world is that at some reverse bias
condition you just have biased it so
much that electrons will be able to
tunnel through from the p-type into the
n-type right here the electrons in the
valence band will be able to tunnel
through into the conduction band and
what happens this IV curve is it goes
zoom begins dropping so if the solar
cell reverse bias see the reverse bias
current or the current at reverse bias
voltage is not low enough in other words
if the PN Junction is not strong enough
you could have a catastrophic failure of
your module we're just shading one of
your cells thankfully this is one of the
testing that are done with the solar
simulator to prevent that failure mode
all right I'll entertain deeper dives
with questions I'll try to keep the
lecture focused on the broader general
topics but if somebody is interested in
in in learning more I'm happy to kind of
dive into there
all right so readings are strongly
encouraged I have interacted with
several of you Joe has interacted with
probably 3n and being the number of
people I've interacted with so far and
really tried to impart the wisdom of PN
junctions so please please please come
to us if if still things are going over
your head you should be able to explain
to your roommates exactly what is going
on into PN Junction define parameters
that determine solar cell efficiency so
now we have a qualitative sense about
where current is flowing where electrons
are moving around what defines the
our outfit how the power output is
changing with illumination condition
we're getting an intuitive sense of all
of this let's start putting some
discrete variables to all of that and
they're a bunch of to letter or
three-letter acronyms with some
subscripts here that we'll get to know
and will become very familiar with over
the next few lectures so how is solar
cell conversion efficiency determinated
determined from that illuminated IV
curve that's our first question and what
I'm going to do is start with our solar
cell IV curve right here this is just
the fourth quadrant okay so notice the
current starts at zero and goes to some
negative values so we're looking in the
fourth quadrant voltage is going from
zero to positive value so again fourth
quadrant we have our our ideal diode
equation here and oh notice one thing I
just changed I to J what just happened
well I and J look very similar but
they're in fact two different variables
most often PV researchers will report a
current density in other words a current
per unit area instead of the actual
current coming out of the solar cell
device so what you've been enjoying here
off of the off of the deck has been
current total current output from that
device and it might be a really tiny
number and it might be difficult to
compare against other sized devices and
so what solar cell researchers often do
is they say okay let's normalize the
current by the area to get a current
density and we'll call current density J
and we'll call current I right so for
calculating power we'll have to use I
I'll have to multiply times of e but if
we're just looking at one solar cell
versus another we can use J is a very
convenient way of comparing one solar
cell versus another cool okay so the
illuminated IV curve looks something
like this right in the fourth quadrant
it goes out a certain amount then it
curves up we just determined that here
in class and that's essentially the
ideal diode equation with a
superposition term this J sub L right
there
so let's parse through this we have the
y-intercept over here at the y-intercept
there is maximum current flowing through
the circuit but no power because voltage
is equal to zero so remember the Fermi
energy is the same on either side the
chemical potentials are the same
either side of the device so there's no
energy gain of the electron traveling
through the external circuit but there's
a maximum current and no power flowing
through that external circuit because
there's no potential to be dropped
across the external resistor the
opposite happens over here at this point
called vo C which we'll call open
circuit voltage the O C stands for open
circuit V voltage open circuit voltage
is just as you would think it is when
your solar cell is in an open circuit
when you see took a sister of scissors
please don't do this and cut the leads
so that your solar cell wasn't
outputting the current through an
external load there would be a bias
voltage built up across the the P and
the N side of the solar cell and it
would be the maximum voltage that could
be supported by that solar cell device
under illumination conditions that's the
open circuit voltage open circuit
because there's no current again
traveling through the external circuit
that's why current is zero right open
circuit and voltage because this is well
it's interesting point because it's the
maximum voltage here represented in the
fourth quadrant and somewhere in between
the point of open circuit voltage and
short circuit current short-circuit
current again because you're
short-circuiting your device current is
flowing through but there's no resistor
there's no external load there's no
power being deposited an external load
somewhere between these two extreme
conditions where there's no power
flowing through the external circuit you
have a maximum power point where there
is a power being deposited across your
external circuit and a lot of it right
that's the maximum power point this is a
point at which the solar cell is
producing the maximum amount of power
output and to represent that slightly
differently what I've done so if I were
to take current times voltage right here
using fourth quadrant data my power
would be a negative number
why because voltage is positive but
current is a negative number all right
so I've multiplied positive a negative
number together to get a negative number
and that just sounds weird who talks
about power output from solar cells
being negative it almost sounds like
powers away into the device so this is
another convention that you're gonna
have to get used to is looking at the IV
curve in the first quadrant so all we've
done is taken the y-axis and multiplied
by negative one so we flipped it up
so bear with me here it's it's it's a
bit tricky to keep all this in your RAM
but here's our short-circuit current
point now here's our open circuit
voltage point our IV curve now is
pointed down before it was going up
because we were in the fourth quadrant
now we flipped essentially just done if
we've done a flip vertical if you will
on our IV curve and we have our current
increasing here going to higher bias
voltages now we can take the product of
the voltage and the current to determine
the power and we obtain a curve that
looks very much like this blue curve
right here that you can see and the
maximum power point is truth in
advertising its active maximum power
it's where this blue curve reaches a
maximum that is the maximum power point
of the solar cell device that is where
the solar cell is outputting the maximum
amount of power and so at this maximum
power point there is a voltage and a
current associated with it that you can
read right off the IV curve and this we
call JMP or current density at the
maximum power point and V NP which is
the voltage at the maximum power point
so so far we've learned essentially four
variables here we have our JSC our vo C
and our JMP and our VMP at that data
point right there questions since I know
you have them
so to ensure that the solar cell device
is operating right here
a couple of things need to happen you
need to have the right illumination
conditions and you need to have the
right load so the two need to be matched
to each other absolutely
and that's where some of the power
electronics come into play so a very
interesting question regarding the
homework question I'm gonna repeat it so
that the microphone can hear it the
homework question the last section the
last homework there was one question
that inquired assumed that the voltage
at the maximum power point is the
bandgap voltage equivalent minus 0.5
volts and the rationale for that
assumption is as follows the open
circuit voltage this point is generally
between 0.35 and 0.4 volts minus the
bandgap well lower than the bandgap so
yeah the bandgap energy minus 0.4 volts
and I can show you a very nice little
paper that describes why that is
essentially has to do in part with
losses inside of the solar cell a
thermodynamic limits of conversion side
of the solar cell device then what we've
done is we've done another another
additional discounting from the vo C to
the maximum power point which we've
assumed is around 0.1 maybe 0.2 volts
notice the shape of the IV curve right
here the maximum power point is
interesting because the voltage of the
maximum power point is almost the vo C
in a good device and the current at the
maximum power point is almost JSC but
not quite right so the discounting from
the vo C to the maximum power point
voltage is not that much as is the
discounting from the short-circuit
current to the maximum power point in a
good device in a bad device this maximum
power point here could be dragged all
the way down here you could have an IV
curve that looks something more like
this instead almost like a resistor at
which point the maximum power outputs
would be a lot less
a lot less than what's shown here in the
blue curve cool all right
so let's continue moving on the
efficiency of the solar cell ADA this
Greek letter ADA is our power out versus
power in our power in is the
illumination intensity given in units of
watts per meter squared so we calculated
this in our very first homework
assignment and realize that the am 1.5
spectrum is around a thousand watts per
meter squared so that's our input power
right here our output power is the
voltage at the maximum power point times
woopsie times the current at the maximum
power point not the current density the
current at the maximum power point so
take this current density and multiply
by area and that's effectively via the
units work out better that way so it
would be either V times I at the maximum
power point or V times J times the area
at the area of the device the area of
the solar cell at the maximum power
point and that's the total power out
actually yeah yeah so as long as the
units are in units of watts per meter
squared yeah down here if this is not
total watts but watts per meter squared
you could still use current density that
would those units would still work out
so be very careful whether you use total
power in or normalized by unit area
power right just keep track of your
units don't do like the professor
okay so we have efficiency here as power
out versus power in the power out being
the maximum power point power in the
power in being the illumination from the
Sun now we're really talking this is
starting to get interesting because it's
beginning to click pieces from lecture
number two come together with what we're
seeing now so this is a solar cell
output power at the maximum power point
and sunlight coming in okay so what I'm
going to do next is I'm going to take
this maximum power point I'm going to
draw a box that ends that starts at the
origin here and the other the other the
opposite the kitty-corner corner of my
box is going to end at the maximum power
point so we'll have some rectilinear
shape that will comprise the maximum
power point and 0 0 the origin has two
of its corners and
box looks like this blue one right here
the area of that box is JMP times VMP
okay
and notice I have another box around
here I have this clear box that starts
at the vo C point and the JSC point and
now I have two rectilinear shapes this
blue one and the clear one right here
the bigger one the bigger one has an
area of JSC times vo C and I'm going to
define a parameter called fill factor
which would be the ratio of these two
areas the ratio of those two boxes the
VMP times JM p divided by the vo C JSC
if this is one which is virtually
impossible to do but if this were one it
would mean that these two boxes were the
same size and the current and voltage of
the maximum power points would be the
current and voltage under short circuit
and open circuit conditions respectively
in real life the this blue box is
smaller than the this clear box right
over here and so the JMP BMP product is
less than the JSC vo C product and by
consequence as well the J and P is less
than GFC V and P is less than vo C so
the ratio of the two boxes is defined as
the fill factor the fill factor
indicates the quality of your diode if
your fill factor is very poor
that means that that son right over
there denotes the maximum power point is
being dragged toward the origin that
means that the area of this blue box is
growing smaller relative to the area of
this clear box the fill factor is going
down that means you're filling less of
this maximum square box function defined
by vo CdSe okay so we have a defined
efficiency as power out divided by power
in power out being the current voltage
product of the maximum power point
divided by the solar insolation fill
factor being defined as the ratio of VMP
iymp product divided by vo C is e
product notice that here I've written
this in terms of total current here in
terms of Kuran
density the area's essentially just
canceled out because you have an area in
the numerator and denominator they
cancel these ratios should be identical
thus we obtain an expression for the
efficiency in terms of fill factor vo C
and is C simply by using this fill
factor definition right here what I've
done is I've multiplied this side of the
equation let's let's just focus right
here where we have fill factor equals
VMP times IM p divided by t OC that's I
see I've moved the denominator up to the
side over here multiplied it by fill
factor and that's my V mpi MP now go
back to that top equation I say my v MP
i MP is now going to be substituted by a
fill factor times V OC times is C and
that's how I get to this equation right
here why why do I go through the effort
of this little numerical manipulation I
do it because these parameters right
here are fairly easy to measure using
the solar simulator that you just put
together right so I can measure the
point at which my voltage is at open
circuit condition I can measure the
current at short-circuit condition and
simply by taking the ratio of those
boxes I can determine what my fill
factor is as well and these break down
or roughly into the the current is going
to be a function roughly again I'm
really painting broad brushstrokes here
the current is going to be roughly a
function of illumination condition and
vault material quality the vo C will be
roughly a function of the interface in
the diode characteristics and the fill
factor is going to be a function of the
interface type characteristics but also
of the resistances within the device and
so from an engineering point of view we
break the solar cell output down into
these three parameters so that we can
better understand what's going wrong
with our solar cell if we have
everything lumped in terms of V MPI and
P it becomes a little bit more obscure
to figure out what exactly is going
wrong with our solar cell device
so the fill factor you would measure
essentially by doing the little analysis
we just did right here yeah exactly so
you'd have to do a voltage current sweep
mm-hmm coolness okay so we have an
expression for efficiency in terms of
fill factor vo C is C and our incoming
power so power out this right here again
is power out divided by power in what is
efficiency matter why do we why do we
care so much about efficiency well the
conversion efficiency determines the
area of solar cells needed to produce a
certain peak power or to think of it
differently the area of solar panels
that is necessary to produce a certain
energy per unit time and many cost scale
with area you have glass encapsulants
the absorber materials within the solar
cell devices themselves the metals that
are used to make contacts the labor
that's used to install the panels you
have a larger panel area you need more
labor to install it the aluminum
interacting and framing materials that
go into holding the panels up in the
field either on a roof or out in the
field so efficiency affects pretty much
everything but the inverter and possibly
some of the soft costs of the project
that includes the architect and the
people who you pay to handle the money
financing so and the lawyers perhaps so
pretty much all of all of the real
material and labor costs are scaling
with area and so efficiency determines
that to a large degree and hence it's a
highly leveraged way to reduce the cost
of solar energy if you do a sensitivity
analysis which you will do in the second
and third parts of the class and look at
the cost of solar and how it scales with
efficiency you'll see that efficiency is
one of the determining factors for cost
in a solar cell device and that's why we
focus on a lot to put into perspective
if the efficiency up there is determined
by the output power versus the input
power if we had 100% conversion
efficiency which is impossible to
achieve thermodynamically impossible to
achieve we would produce a certain
amount of energy per unit time or
certain amount of peak power with this
panel right there say that's the size of
our field installation if we had a 33%
efficiency cell which is closer to space
grade solar cells we
three times that area so 3 times the
encapsulants three times the glass three
times the labor to install it and if we
had a 20% efficiency say high-end but
but still a commercial solar module
that's something you'd need to get from
NASA but something that you could buy
from a supplier you would need five
times that area whereas if you had a 10%
efficiency module which is more
approaching the area of some relatively
inexpensive solar cells you would need
ten times that area so if you're doing a
cost analysis this is why efficiency
matters it might still be cheaper to use
this instead of to use this over here if
it might very well be more expensive
when you do the math and figure out how
much it costs to deposit those materials
with a very low throughput deposition
process and very high cost in my Soviet
but am I not the material costs might
end up whopping you and so a simple
equation that calculates all these
parameters in the material costs the
module efficiency essentially the
material wafer costs are being
calculated in dollars per meter squared
they're saying how many dollars go into
producing a meter squared of this
material and the efficiency is over here
and this is just a very simple back of
the envelope calculation type of way of
estimating the cost of a solar system so
if you say okay I'm willing to pay more
for a high-efficiency cell because I'm
using less area you can use this type of
calculation to get to the answer quickly
it's not a levelized cost of electricity
analysis it's not using discounted
capital flows and so forth which we'll
get to later on in class this is a
really back of the envelope engineering
approach to estimating cost of a solar
system so I think this is a great place
to stop and if anybody has a pitch
concerning their project ideas class
project ideas I'd like to invite them to
the front now the class project mind you
is really the capstone of this class to
66 to 67 so if you have an idea a fun
idea for a class project I'd invite you
to give a pitch up here at the front of
class or you're welcome to send around
an email to the class Lister
you